الى موضوع يدمج بين حب السيارات وبين
السوق والبيئه ففي زمن الحفاظ على المناخ
السيارات متهم دائما وخصوصا سوبر سيارات
هذه السيارات الفارهه بالتحديد قررت
ملاقاه زبائنها في الجانب الاخضر عبر
صناعه الدراجات كهربائيه لهم تخيلوا مثلا
دراجه لمبرجيني او بوغاتي فبكل بساطه من
يركب سياره بورش او لمبرجيني اذا فكر في
ان يركب دراجه فبالتاكيد سيفكر في هذه
العلامات اولا لشراء دراجه هوائيه
وكهربائيه سعرها ثمانيه الاف يورو الا ان
الان بورش هي الماركه الاكثر طموحا في هذا
المجال تستعد للتنافس وبشراسه وهناك
ماركات فارهه اخرى تسير في الاتجاه نفسه
سنتعرف اكثر على هذا الاتجاه وهذا التوجه
مع علاء سرحان اليك على
ماركات السيارات الرياضيه الكبرى ستجدها
في الاسواق دراجات هوائيه كهربائيه ستطور
بورشا
باحدث المحركات والبطاريات الكهربائيه
والبرامج الحاسوبيه الخاصه بالدراجات وتضع
خطه كبيره لعام 2005
تشير الماركه الرياضيه الى انها تهدف
للاستحواذ على 80% من اجمالي مبيعات السوق
سنه 2030 وستكون رائده في مجال التنقل
المستدام وذلك على الرغم من ان دراجتها
سيصل سعرها الى 8000 يورو مقارنه بالفين
او ثلاثه الاف يورو لمركات الدراجات من
علامات منتشره حاليا من جانبها دخلت ماركه
ميني كوبر مجال الدراجات الكهربائيه مع
الاعلان الاخير لشركه انجل للدراجات
الذكيه بانها ستصمم وتصنع في فرنسا طرازا
من الدرجات الكهربائيه لميني كوبر ايضا
نجحت رينو نهايه عام
2022 بتسويق دراجات سباق تدخل الياف
الكربون في صناعتها بسعر 9000 يورو ومن
تصميم شركه لابيا بهدف الترويج لمركتها
الرياضيه البين اطلقت شركات كثيره اخرى
دراجاتها الهوائيه او مركبات سكوتر في
المرحله الاخيره من امثال لمبرجيني
وبوجاتي
[موسيقى]
نذهب معكم الى بيروت والاعلام الرياضي من
هناك جورج سويديه ينضم الينا جورج يسعد
هالصباح واهلا بك معنا في صباح العربيه
جورج اليوم لماذا تتجه السيارات الفارهه
وكبرى السيارات العلامات التجاريه الكبيره
الى صناعه دراجات كهربائيه بدلا من
التركيز على سيارات كهربائيه مثلا
صباح الخير نادين لكل المشاهدين بصباح
العربيه يعني طبعا السيارات الفاخره خاصه
السوبر الرياضيه مثل ما ذكرتوا بالتقرير
يعني عم نحكي عن بورشا المصنع الالماني
العملاق بعالم السيارات الرياضيه عم نحكي
سيارات معروفه جدا بدات فعلا بتصنيع
السيارات كهربائيه اصلا لانه كل كل
الاتجاه باوروبا رايح لحتى عام 2035 تكون
السيارات كلها تقريبا بالقاره العجوز
السيارات كهربائيه من هلا لحولت 12 سنه
للامام اكيد رح يكون في اختراعات جديده من
بينها كمان شغله صارت ترند اليوم وهي
الدراجه الهوائيه الكهربائيه يلي سابقتهم
عليها بعض الشركات المعروفه اصلا بتصنيع
الدراجات الهوائيه اليوم الماركت بده يلحق
نفسه
وكل هالسيارات المعروفه طبعا الشركات
المعروفه بدها تفوت ايضا بهذا الماركت
اللي هو ماركت الغوغرين وعم بتصنع دراجات
هوائيه رائ عه جدا معموله من الكربون
فايبر
بديزاين رائع ايضا مثل التايكان
يعني جورج بس لانه اليوم هلا عم نشوف
بالشارع مثلا اليكتريكوتر وحتى يعني
الالكتريك بايك بس انا اذا بدي اشوف كمان
دراجات مصنعه من شركات مثل لمبرجيني
وبوجاتي يعني كيف بدي اتخيل يكون شكل
البايك
والله صراحه نادين انا كان عندي حشريه
كبيره ادخل على جوجل وشوف شو راح يكون
شكلها
بايك فعلا ديزاين ولا اجمل
شكل شكل كتير حلو حيكون هلا الحلو انو
اللي معه هالدراجه هيدي راح تساعدوا
بحوالي 25 كيلو متر بالساعه زياده كسرعه
يعني اضافه
للدواسات للبدل اللي راح يكون رح تعطيه 25
كيلو متر اضافي من الفور يعني اذا عنده
طلعه او اذا عنده مشوار طويل خاصه يعني
اليوم بالساحل بالمدن كتير راح يعوز هذا
النوع من الدراجات من درجات الهويه
الكهربائيه وبالنهايه رح يسوق بورشا بس
السعره راح يكون
10,000 واكثر حسب الديزاين حسب اذا معموله
كلها من الالياف الكربون او لا طيب جورج
يعني ما في كمان اليوم مدن عملها بتحضر
استخدام السكوتر الكهربائي
ومدن كمان بدها تمنعها تماما انه احنا
لوين ماشيين انه الناس عمالها بتصنع
وبنفس الوقت المدن عم تمنع
مختلفه عن الالكترك سكوتر بصراحه يعني
بعدنا عم نحكي اليوم بدراجه هوائيه واليوم
كل العالم بتصور مسموحه في الدراجه
الهوائيه وخاصه بمعظم المدن الاوروبيه
اكثر شيء بنشوف اليوم الدراجي الهوائيه
كمان اليوم الشركات رايحه لهذا الموضوع
لانه متل ما ذكرتي ايضا نادين السكوتر
اليوم خطره يعني عم تسبب حوادث كثير
واليوم صارت صارت موجوده بمعظم المدن انا
كنت بنيوزينه بالفتره كتير سهل اليوم
تحصلي على سكوتر حيالله شخص معه الموبايل
تبعه على اي ابلكيشن بيعمل سكان للباركود
موجود على سكوتر بياخذها من الشوارع بشكل
كتير سهل شو ما كان عمره شو ما كان الوضع
يعني هيدي شغله اليوم كمان عم تسبب حوادث
صراحه على المره عم بكون خطره على
السيارات لانه كمان كل بلد في عنده قوانين
السير تبعه ومش كل الناس ومش كل السباح
بيعرفوا هذا الموضوع
كتير بنشكرك على وجودك معنا من بيروت
الاعلام اللبناني جورج سويدي شكرا جورج